redick times indeed Simmons the position
that Duncan a foul that it's indeed
right there in the game that's what you
want to be doing it down the stretch
when the game's on the line you're in
the behind they see Donna here at
Johnson dropping a dime on Ben's Senate
who was able to just jump over been
tipped it simple
Simmons in that time the ball movement
much more crisper than it's been so far
here in the third Sixers on the break
we're going to be even more trouble
because you've got more people to fill
them dawn Simmons on a breakaway
[Applause]
sham it by the way as I believe Simmons
got a piece of the rock there leads the
parade and slams for two then Simmons
has been the man here in the second step
play again soon as he catches it he
knows where pin is returning the favor
and beat who has been quiet offensively
in the game just one bucket Wow a
brilliant play by Joe elf who is on the
floor took some punishment but finally
got it to Ben Simmons 33 a year but the
numbers now have exceeded that no one
talks about his contract is off the roof
talk to me about Benson and to what he
just did the play was drawn up the
Sixers interrupted that the thing went
to hell
Yvette's of Mike muscala who is turning
out to be quite the high post passer
that last exchange again the high-low
that's a perfect path JJ's got to get
out of there one of them's gotta get out
of there could look yeah indeed the
pick-and-roll works perfectly between
Redick who set up Simmons well done by
JJ there's the two-man game you see how
much attention JJ draws been left open
well use the backboard for any kind of
support Davis gave it away
[Music]
beat Ben Simmons and see right there off
of the steeled Shannon gets a tool but
he could score and he can score in
bunches we talked about again that
cavalier game last year when he was in
Cleveland Wow Ben Simmons finished the
job compliments a firkin cork ma Wendy
seems likes that and the defender coming
over to interject looks like he got a
piece of it Ben's still able to catch it
yes there's the foul right first half
for Blake Griffin final seconds no fouls
to give here for Detroit JJ Redick fire
flash by trouble ball knocked loose
thrown up shotgun go thrown down by
sevens will a second remaining
rondae hollis-jefferson who
shaken up earlier is back the Sixers
come up with a turnover
[Applause]
teammates going over and giving them
some love it's number 23 with the red
headband tonight so number 25 in the red
headband
well those tough passes yeah I'm sure
you've run the floor and had some really
weird messes no pants they're simply a
slab for Simmons he is playing with a
lot more emotion after showing some
unusual emotion and picking up a tactic
yeah and you can see how an adversary
tighten up you look at the box he scores
31 points in a loss of top three sevens
muscala laid it on a platter form and
Ben Simmons at 6:10 fly and hi who all
time and franchise wins of course number
one the great
Philadelphia native the Hall of Famer
the lake chat Rams after the lost couple
of nights ago in Portland
on this one
second straight falling to 21 and 16 a
sim and some wizardry there as he
knocked it off my teams hat here it is
persimmons
compliments of indeed it's nice when the
center could drop a dime on the point
guard
Chandler back facing design the timeout
Ben Simmons with the one hand switch the
season like 15 his career-high
[Applause]
joella's first assistant nice little
ball movement that's a nice look right
there - cutting pen Simmons in traffic
for Nick defenders around them between
them Obama becoming the elite player
that he's become defensively
the to explain what just happened there
at Benson a matching up here with a
rookie shaman throw it down
compliment to TJ McConnell his fourth
assistants that play again nice little
back screen from Jimmy two-man game
point guard two point guard get the
feeling that this Philadelphia team he
was going to look a lot different in
April then the GM absolutely and beat
had the chance to line up the seams
Simmons cleaned it up more look at
Simmons here lucious you start that now
or do you hold off the await that's a
question mark for the coaches lob for
Simmons in the finish on the great pass
by TJ McConnell just kind of loud the
Nuggets to get back in it
it's a lob for Simmons and that time he
turned it over Ben Simmons getting the
dunk on the law compliments Alandra
shaman here's the screen where he came
from as a freshman to when he finally
laughed and Ben the ups and down through
the NBA gia never happy with easy basket
in the paint for Philly he's dueling
Willie cauley-stein the 7 footer from
Kentucky frustrated boom is right on his
right foot knee last year in their
matchup and a couple of blocks on him in
a final minute of the game
oh yes another dunk by Ben Simmons any
time the Sixers now have it out of the
timeout late great
jazz musicians then it's another easy to
off the nice pass from Jimmy Buffett
moved by Plumlee he would not be at the
top of the list of offensive options but
that was well done Simmons and looked at
alone any punches are on the bucket look
at this a little mistake on the exchange
and Simmons is like ee Beasley thinks
he's just ketchup and that puts Plumlee
at a deficit that seven says you just
paid a big-time mistake
[Music]
his first in two tries decisions have
taken on the 8th grade says Simmons got
the block 1 Smith goes racing down the
floor when they count it nope no basket
HT slam a heart condition and then
Simmons right back at you
the double pump backward slash trail
starting to heat up
lady Jung is up to thirteen point seven
strong I school so I know very well mom
and dad should be extremely proud of the
young man that they raise sevens attacks
the goal his ability to play the point
guard position but also get beard that's
right start your free trial on ESPN plus
by downloading the ESPN app were
visiting espn.com and I find that
highlight on ESPN plus it some point
Simmons with a crush they give up a
basket how quick they get it up the
floor and bead with the fatally Simmons
and one express yourself is only
averaging nine point one rebounds per
guard now we know that he's the banks
open for Chris Middleton guides a second
leading scorer shade under 18 Simmons on
the attack again and he's averaging just
over forty two in the previous three
games against the Sixers who get another
Duncan compliments event Simmons and
that's enough for James forego Toolman
then Ben's splitting two defenders
finishes with the right awesome great
family two very supportive and loving
Simmons another dunk for him that's
three first quarter dunks two of them
for Simmons here in the first sheep and
in action fake handoff to JJ as he gets
a lot of looks like that the things we
talked about what to watch they're there
for a reason
but wait to pass as well from it be
sporting the new headband redick again
lease give up to Simmons who slams it
back for a reason it wasn't because of
his jump shot it was because he knows
how to impact the game there's an
example of impact here because the
all-star expressing himself coming right
down to paint and what happens when you
go smalls girl you're now asking guys
trying to avoid the block shot often
times it makes you just miss the shot
when you get it off
Simmons with six to shoot
nasty finished by Simmons Ben Simmons
headlining Kyrie Irving my goodness
Simmons wide open
we had a 2-1 series lead Serrano won the
next two sixes trying to force a game
seven which would be Sunday in Toronto
our benzotine team allowed that here's
Butler out of you and be dry
captain discussions
[Applause]
pushing Kawhi Leonard up he's just
positioning so what's up you guys this
Taylor Brooks with bleacher report make
sure that you subscribe for some more
video content